[inaudible].
So today I'm really excited to
have you here to talk a little bit,
not just about the coffee, but your path
to getting to where you have today, um,
to talk to you guys and to see how Colby
has been able to successfully live a
life of work life balance,
doing things that he's passionate about
and really just like having an idea and
going for it.
So maybe we just start out talking about
how you decided that you wanted to get
into the business.
Sure. Thank you guys for all coming in.
It's pretty, pretty awesome to be here in
San Francisco at Google serving
coffee to you all. Google is,
um, I'll totally get to what
you said. That's good. Yeah,
Google is actually one of our first
back in the day clients actually that a,
we ever sold coffee to
kind of, uh, more um,
more big league client out of Santa Cruz.
One of the first people we sold to a was
on the original Google campus. And, uh,
our 1950 blend in fact that we sell,
one of our most popular selling blends
was named after the 1950 [inaudible]
building at Google.
So big ups,
but it's our trademark. So, uh, um,
but so yeah,
I mean I grew up not really,
I guess in the bay area by then, that
couple of hours north of San Francisco,
uh,
in an area.
MMM.
Kind of Napa, Mendocino, Lake County,
Sonoma county families from Sonoma county.
And I grew up, uh, their farming,
Paris in wine grapes and with,
uh,
in the old kind of classic farming family
and work a card and then play hard but
mostly work hard. And, um, you know,
my dad went to Uc Davis,
did that whole thing and so kind of was
really instilled in early life about
really caring about food and
produce where things come from.
And also seeing really early on how,
how there are a lot of people out there
doing amazing work in food and they're
very rarely recognized or
even less rewarded for that.
And so that was kind of always on my mind
in this back back burner, um, which we,
I guess we can circle back to.
But uh,
it definitely instilled to me
these kind of core values that,
that there's something, there's
something out there that exists for, for,
for doing great work in food and
that there was an opportunity there.
But um, that more was a
revelation I had later.
What kind of really kicked me into just
getting into coffee is the cliche reason
most people get into coffee, which is you
go to college, you go to coffee shops,
you hang out there. Cool. You try to
order cool drinks. You usually don't,
you know,
my,
my gateway to coffee was
drinking mochas that I hated.
I loved everything about it
except for this espresso taste.
When I was in high school,
I'm trying to go play,
I used to play jazz and going and playing
like jazz combos and going to coffee
shops and just sort of being
enamored with this coffee house vibe,
this coffee house culture.
Then you go to college and then you end
up studying there and hang out there.
And you find the cool wine and you go
to the one that's cool and not the other
ones because it's not cool.
And just kind of always in the
back of my mind thought Cliche Lee,
you know,
coffee's cool and wouldn't it be cool
someday to do something in coffee?
Didn't more in the back back of the mind.
I went and did other things and studied
environmental science and I did Gis and
did that for like five years and did a
lot of computer stuff and then wanted to
really kind of
do something on my own.
Which I guess maybe kind of coming back
to that basis of growing up on a family
farm,
when you're in a family that farms you
don't like clock in for work, you just,
it just is life. So I always just
sort of thought I'd work for myself.
And then after five years of
not doing that, I kind of did.
I was like a contractor, but uh, I
really wanted to just start my own
business. And so this was while
you were in school? In College?
This was right after I finished college
by still the Din the college kind of in
a college town, um, up north Chico. And,
uh,
we're,
I ended up living and going to
school and other things and um,
we can get back to those other
things. Yeah, that was cool.
Learned a lot about myself
and um, yeah. Uh, no,
it was great though. I,
it is, it was perfect.
It was a path I was supposed
to be on and but yeah,
getting into wanting to start my own
business and ultimately taking that,
that leap. But when, when I
thought like, well, what do I,
what is the business I want to do?
I kind of came back to this thought that
had always been incubating in the back
of my mind that, well, coffee's
cool. Coffee shops are cool.
Yeah.
I loved,
I loved music and I just love this.
What I thought at that time was how
did very direct tie to coffee houses.
I collect vinyl,
played in bands,
only played analog instruments and
somehow coffee fit in the same strata
as those,
those elements in my life.
And so with out of time
without any experience.
But I went to talk to the guy and the
cool town in the cool coffee shop in town
to ask him,
would you mind kind of what does it
take to do this? How do I be great?
What does great look like?
Which is an important lesson I've kind
of tried to always carry with me moving
forward. But, and he said, actually, I'm
thinking about selling this coffee house.
Are you interested in buying it?
One thing led to another and three
months later I was standing in the coffee
shop that I owned with not exactly
understand what to do, understaffed,
um, and really had to just
feel the weight of it,
all of what it's like to take that
risk of that commitment and just say,
screw it. Like, let's do this.
So do you feel like it was a,
it was an out of comfort zone
type thing where you're like,
I'm in a coffee shop and some of these
presenting this to me and I hadn't
planned on it, but now
you're, this opportunity is,
was it an easy decision for you to just
say, Yep, I'm going to do it or no.
How did you feel going into that?
I don't know if it was an easy decision,
but
I kind of have a point of view on certain,
on these things,
which is that,
okay,
decisions are hard. So sometimes
it's best just to corner yourself,
you know, burn your bridge,
whatever you want to say. But I,
you know, make the commitment
before I, I'm all about analysis.
I wasn't analysis and an
analyst for five years.
So I'm all about analysis and research
is my favorite thing to do in life.
Probably one of them.
But at some point you just jump and you
won't ever have all the information.
And I do believe, uh, uh, saying
that one's Kinda came to me. Um,
my sister who was up here was,
can bear witness.
And the classic plays where you gather
all life information to make important
decisions,
which is after a prince
concert at a blackjack table
at like two in the morning.
Um,
but I ended up talking to someone who
worked in technology and I guess it built
a pretty successful company and we ended
up talking for a long time and I had
just said,
if you could give some piece of advice
to a young person who's wanting to really
do something special and really get
to maybe in a position like you are,
and not necessarily like,
I don't know if he was wealthy,
I'm pretty sure he might've been,
but just more I could just tell that he
had gotten to some place that he felt
very satisfied with and he just,
without even blinking,
just looked right at me and said,
take chances and over extend yourself.
Okay.
And that's sort of in my
goto since that night.
And in a way it's this permission that
some dude at a blackjack table after
prince concerts gave me.
So of course it's valid
and totally trustworthy.
I feel like, um, those little
things come into your life.
It just different times that reinforce
that you are in the right path and doing
the right thing. I mean here you are now
co founder of a global company, right?
Yeah. Yeah. So that's awesome.
Yeah. And I think too, uh, I
mean to answer your question, it,
the decision what,
it wasn't easy,
but just feeling like I
had this permission to make
it and then just jump in,
choosing to jump and set of choosing to,
let's just wait a little bit more.
I'm more of a jumper for better or worse,
but I think there is something
to that that, you know,
in life you have to make a lot of choices.
And so I think getting comfortable with
making choices are becoming decisive,
knowing that you're knowing you're
for sure not going to be right. Um,
was it the best decision I could've
made my life. I'll never know.
But it was the one I made and it got
me here. It was a stepping stone.
So it was definitely a critical decision.
Um,
which then led me to my next decision,
which was to start verve with,
uh, my business partner,
Ryan. He's over here. Hi Ryan.
He doesn't like being outed,
but
so you had your store in Chico or
you're shopping Chico and what,
what was the path then to opening
up your own, your own brand?
Well,
one year into it,
after being super understaffed in you
learn a lot when you don't have anyone
you can,
when you know that there no one
else's responsibility but yours,
there's no like that. There's no
boss you just, you look for, right.
And you realize, shit, I met and
do you just, okay now what do I,
what am I going to do? And you
met, you have to make calls. Um,
a lot of bad decisions,
a lot of great decisions,
but decisions on the less
that move you forward.
And I'm learning a lot about having the
right people on the bus and learning
what it's like to have wrong people on
the bus and have to fire people and do
all these things was my first
kind of year in business.
But what came through it
besides the business parts and,
okay,
yeah.
Sales Tax and all these bookkeeping
things that are not my big passion but are
super important.
If you want to run a business,
do not think they're not important.
Uh,
hire an accountant before you
hire anybody else. Um, and uh,
yeah.
Was how much I was falling in love with
coffee because when I got into coffee,
it wasn't for coffee,
it was for a coffee house culture.
But after one year into it spending
every day doing it, becoming a Barista,
just and connecting
with a couple of people,
friend Shaun wide who now does flat white,
he's a ceramicist for a
lot of coffee shops around.
He was our first employee at Verve,
um,
a few other people and dropping into the
world that became like Barisa culture.
Third wave coffee.
I was,
I became completely enamored with
coffee itself and as an analyst and the
researcher,
yeah,
this like trapdoor opened and I like
fell through it and it was just the
universe of just where
does coffee come from?
Why are some coffees taste different
than others? What's happening?
And what's up with rusty and different
origins, what's up of different varieties.
I have to know everything
about all of this.
And I was thinking about how do I learn,
how do I jump in cause I just had this
coffee shop and I thought about my friend
from college who I played music with who
had been in coffee it's whole life and
was a home roaster and was the biggest
coffee guy knew. And Ryan Donovan,
my business partner and we started,
I called him one day just from a park
bench in front of a farmer's market and
said, dude, we should start a
coffee roasting company together.
He had just moved back from Portland,
uh, work in coffee shops, coffee shops,
coffee roasters, wholesale,
everything. And long story short,
we just met up a few days later,
started looking for spots and within a
couple of months we signed a lease and
started verve in Santa
Cruz. Yes, in Santa Cruz.
We almost, we originally gonna open in
San Francisco and at this time to 2005,
we opened the only third wave coffee
company in all of California was ritual.
I'm Valencia it all Cali,
they carried stump town and
that was it for the whole state.
So at this point in time,
if you opened a cool company anywhere,
people everywhere, I knew about it. Uh,
we were gonna open in San Francisco then
almost open in like Berkeley, Berkeley,
Oakland at the last minute, right before
we were supposed to sign the lease,
I got a call from Ryan.
He just said, dude,
I'm living in Santa Cruz
because I got my lady,
we're probably to get married some day,
which he did.
And they have two awesome kids,
uh,
and said, this is the lifestyle I want
to have. I want to able to surf on it,
all the ride mountain bikes. I want
to build a company where I want to be.
And so it kind of fell
apart for like a week or so.
And then I kind of thought, well,
let's just go look at Santa Cruz.
And one thing led to another and we
ended up making the commitment there and
said, well, let's see if we can
make noise even though we're here,
which we didn't think we'd be
able to to do. But you know,
fortunately we were able to do that.
That's awesome. Um, so
basically it goes to
the idea of work life balance and
choosing a location that can adapt to the
things that you want to do in
life where you can pursue this,
this passion that you have, a dream
that you have that you want to achieve,
but also to be able to maintain.
Like, I want to go surfing,
I want to go mountain biking or whatnot.
So can you talk a little bit more about
that and how you're able to achieve that?
It's pretty cool to rent survey question,
right?
It was definitely in the ethos of
starting a company, like as I described,
but I think fast forward
into present day or just,
it's hard, you know? I mean it requires
you to saying that you want to do that.
And then, I mean work
life balance, you know,
I've heard like in a work
life harmony, you know, um,
Bezos talks about that and I think it's
interesting to think about it because it,
it,
it really determine,
it's really dependent on the individual
where they're at in their life,
their age, what they want, what's,
and what's energizing them to
determine is that a light switch,
is it a Yin and Yang?
And they have to be opposites and that's
how they are distinct but also fuel
each other.
How you,
or is it a fader or is it like I think
of the harmony is like multiple things at
once,
but it's like c major or maybe it's
like d minor depending on how your mood.
I Love d minor. Um, and uh,
but
it takes, I think it takes
practice and again, it just,
it's different for different people.
I mean,
for sure.
You know,
one thing for sure as an exercise is
just, again, like I like corner myself.
So is to force yourself into doing
something where you for sure can only be
thinking about that one thing. So whether
that's, a lot of people have sports,
you know, like surfing or mountain
biking, get into your like flow state,
which I know can happen on computers
and a lot of different ways I've
experienced.
But if you take it into like outside of
work and you can pick up an activity or
an exercise, there's some thing
or yoga float tanks, I don't know,
whatever it is for people.
I like all that. But uh,
that you just have to be in that
moment because it requires all of your
attention and that's like one way to break
whether it's you take always have two
days off in a row or every year you take
off for a few weeks ago do something or
you know, so there's a lot
of different ways to do that,
but I like trying to figure out,
find activities that
requiring all your attention.
That definitely makes sense.
I think that just in general, the culture
here is, or not here as in Google,
but here as in the US is that it's very
work focused and to be on the clock all
the time and to make sure you're
doing everything all the time.
But there's something to be said about
breaking that up and doing the things
that you love,
making work,
even something that you love and making
sure you're in the right headspace.
And um, I admire the fact
that you're able to go to,
to so many different
activities and focus on them.
And the drive that you
have is really amazing.
So I'm just going to call that out.
I mean, I think you were saying
about enjoying what you do. To me,
that's a big part of it. I mean,
that's why I started my own company,
but I just, I, I used to do all of
our orientations for like six years.
Every single employee
that ever worked at Verve,
I did every employee's orientation.
I used to just tell people like,
we want people that want be here and
if like you don't want it to be here,
I want you to to quit,
which is hard and,
and not meaning. Like, cause we're so
cool and like you don't belong, but no,
just like I don't, I will help you find
that, you know, put in notice whatever.
I'll help you find a different job,
but you owe it to yourself to do
something you're passionate about. Uh,
whether it's starting your own business
or, or not because people are different,
energized in different
ways or being part of the,
a team that has a huge lever
for change like Google,
um, or how you get empowered in
your own way. Um, but I don't,
I do the one thing that kind of the work
life balance when I feel like it's this
dichotomy that I don't like is the feeling
that you would just do something that
you,
that it could mean you put
up with something that you
don't love to do or even
like to do, but you only have
to do it eight hours a day.
And then you get to live your life,
which is cool.
I mean there's like a lot of the best
musicians I've known the world that day,
jobs that more or whatever. But I do, I,
I do think it is important to just find
what you're passionate about or fine,
how to be passionate in what you do
because it just makes everything better.
And to me a little bit of,
that's like the harmony part,
which is that you know that your work
should be part of what fulfills you.
Right.
And I think that that shows
in your shops as well. Um,
I've been to a few of them and
the staff is very friendly.
They all do their job really well and
they seem to actually enjoy being there.
So maybe you can talk about how
you incorporate that into your,
into your company culture.
Yeah, I'm telling them that they can
quit if they don't really want it.
I want to tell people they have to quit
if they don't want to be here. But um,
because I think that's what people
should do but uh, for themselves.
But it is something that's probably
been the most difficult thing as we've
scaled. Um, because as you,
when you have one shop or the small team,
right,
I forget the number of people talk
about is like a for a small tribe,
10 1530 people. But once you
blow it, once you exceed that,
there's a lot that happens is innately,
especially when you have the
small group leaders are present,
this trickle down effect.
It just,
it's is very obvious to everyone that
it's easier to set expectations without
having things so explicitly written.
But as you scale,
you know,
40 50,
80 102 hundred employees we
have at verve now, oh Nah man,
please Google House.
But I'm sure it's more than 200.
That's probably about 200 and this room.
And uh,
but it's the hardest thing to do is to
scale culture because at a certain point
you have to like literally be thinking,
how am I engineering culture now?
And it feels
there's a,
a falseness that's a word that comes
with that idea that your engineering
culture.
But I kind of became a numbered with that
a little bit because what you're just
trying to,
it's,
it's a point of being self reflective
about being reflective and self aware as a
brand and as a company about and to figure
out how you want to communicate that
and to build that into the culture at,
to set those expectations and
then ultimately have, you know,
the right people on the bus.
I mean, I'm a big fan of,
I know maybe it's like old school
now, but like, you know, good to great
Jim Collins getting the right people on
the bus. There's no substitute for that.
You cannot,
you cannot train somebody and to get in
it like you have to just get the right
people and then figure
out how to empower them.
And that's what we're,
that's what we've done at verve.
And that's what I think we're really
focused on this this next year and beyond,
is to really figure out how to build
a framework so that people really feel
empowered and can sort of channel their
own entrepreneurial spirit and what they
do. And that, that's a
little bit of, I think what,
what you experience when
you come in diversion,
you have people smile and greet at you.
We'd been criticized for being
too friendly. Whoops. You know,
cause some people think it's fake,
but I don't ever want that.
I didn't want there to ever
be a fake vibe at verve. It's,
it's not that we don't tell people like,
and then make sure you put on your smile
and get your flavor badges and like,
it's not about that. It's like we tell
people just be normal. Like, just be real.
If you're not someone who
would say smaller, say hey,
how's it going to someone who like
walks in and stands in front of you,
then like, okay, that's like, that's your
world, but maybe this isn't, you know,
for, it's not the right
culture for you. So we're just,
we just try to find friendly,
outgoing people that wanted,
like take care of you and
tell them to just be normal.
I'm sorry.
I guess leading into that,
we can go on the flip side of that to
your relationship with your vendors,
the people who provide,
um, the coffee grounds.
You want to talk about that a little bit?
Sure. The grounds, the
grounds, I'm sorry, the beans.
I'm just kidding. People see
our restaurant sometimes and uh,
and um, see Brian Santa Cruz where
we have our restaurant, it's all,
we've always created this like whole
fishbowl effect with our rescue. We,
it's very transparent where what we do
and you can come see it and they always
see these big round drums, slit
cylinders rather. And they say,
Oh, is that, is that where you grind
the beans? But there's a giant grinders,
but there are coffee roasters. But
anyway, I'm just kidding. That's good.
Call me out. Um, yeah. Uh,
yeah, for sure. I mean,
we call it, uh, like our sourcing
program at verve farm level,
we call it a is does go full
circle for me personally,
back to grind up on a farm and
with a parent who was with parents.
But My, you know, my dad, we're going,
my mom growing up on a farm myself and
then my dad also grew up a farm and going
to UC Davis,
it was really instilled and being like
really take care of business people that
never did shortcuts and just kept,
you know,
the orchards and vineyards,
meticulous all year round.
Never had garbage on the ground.
Everything's just perfect.
And the fruit you would
show that, you know, my,
they grew some of the best, uh,
somebody on blank and Paris anywhere in,
in the world and,
but they never really got
pretty premiums for it.
They're just treated as a commodity
and it's like kids on laptops, spine.
What's this? How much is the price? How
much is it over here? 4 cents cheaper.
Pound over here, buy it here, send it
to the grocer with no sense of light.
But what's the difference in quality?
Who are these people?
What's their background? Is
there any value? Add weekend,
you know, like the, just,
it's just, just a
commodity and coffee, uh,
being one of the more traded commodities
in the world. I mean for prospective,
how much coffees out there Starbucks by,
it's like 2.2 and a half
percent of the world's coffee.
So there's the other 97 and a half
percent of the world's coffee that's not
being sold by Starbucks.
That's how big the market is.
It's a commodity market.
And so while we got into verve and
wanting to figure out how we could do
something different,
and the tipping point of what became
kind of third wave coffee was to go find
the best coffees in the world
and that there was this,
this new new world
happening of discovery and,
and just extraordinary flavors coming
into the world of coffee and we sought to
go find them.
So when we started for the first,
I'm not sure if for six, seven years or
so, I was, I was our only coffee buyer.
So I traveled like four months out
of the year all around the globe,
Central America, South
Africa, South America,
east Africa for like four months out of
the year traveling to go find coffees.
Meat Producers.
Go back and see those producers again,
discover new gyms out,
position people on coffees
and to really help find them,
but also to help be part of what is
maybe the point of the spear of, uh,
enormous global industry.
But to just help
say we're willing to pay you
equitably for this work you do,
which produces an extraordinary
Lee high quality product,
that same product that
we're then going to take
and sell at a higher premium
than we maybe some people sell.
Definitely compared to
what most people sell. Uh,
because there's a value that
it's worth it and we think
that
it gets some off the rails here.
But I was just like this fully steered
away from it how being nice to producers.
But um, which we are,
but no, but to me I can,
the economic lever is like
the most important lever.
If you want to help a
farmer pay them more,
you can go ask every single one of our
farmers and say, what do you really need?
And they're just going to say,
just pay me more. They're like,
a lot of people think like farmers.
It's like a pity thing and all this
and I don't, I hate that marketing.
I hate that kind of cause marketing for
coffee for producers because growing up
on a farm like my grandpa,
so bad ass, my dad
hard as nails.
Like those are not,
those are the last people on earth
that want your pity or like farmers,
they just want to be treated fairly and
to feel like their hard work is like
worth it.
They have enough stress with like mother
nature and a lot of other things than
to,
so we sort of built our business
around that and you know,
and it really starts with customers
paying more for a cup of coffee because
there's x amount of dollars in a cup
of coffee and then everyone has their
margins and I believe in supply chain.
I mean you need,
you know, someone's drinking
the coffee, going back in time,
someone's delivering the coffee,
roasting the coffee, buying the coffee,
importing the coffee,
someone export at the coffee,
someone shipped it and insured it in
between someone milled the coffee for
export right before that somebody
processed the freshly picked cherries.
And then someone grew those cherries.
You need all of those steps.
I mean people can be vertically
integrated or whatever,
but those steps don't go away.
And everyone,
I think it's cool if everyone
has a sustainable business,
transparent business model. Uh,
like the middlemen concept is that
it middlemen to me are more like as a
term tied to people that operate within a
supply chain that take advantage of it
without transparency and exploit people
on either side of them.
But as far as steps in a supply chain,
everybody's critical and we all through
those points of the supply chain,
we treat all of them with as much respect
and honesty and transparency as we can
because at one end of that supply,
at the other end of the supply chain
is the producer and at the end that the
other end,
the bookmarks are literally
coffee drinkers and coffee
growers and they're the
most disconnected physically
and emotionally. You know,
like people that are like growing
coffee on the hills and Santa Barbara,
Honduras totally can't necessarily
relate to people that work at Google but,
or maybe vice versa. But those are
like the two most important parts.
Everyone else is facilitating.
Yeah. You could say we're curators,
we go find this stuff. This is
cool, this is hot, this is not,
but you need someone to throw
it on money at the one end.
I needed someone to be willing
to produce at the other end.
And those two need to kind of
have that synergy between the two.
So we work really hard in our whole
business to create that bridge and sort of
foster that economy.
So yeah,
I was really curious that decision
to be in Santa Cruz and not one of the
obvious places that you were probably
thinking about being,
um,
a lot of us here in marketing or touch
marketing and I would think, you know,
you have to go where the businesses
are, where the people would be. Um,
how was marketing for you and getting
your name out and getting going when maybe
you're thinking about just, you know,
surfer surfer is walking in for coffee.
It's not necessarily someone
that's gonna I dunno,
like a business person in the valley.
Yes. Being aware that people
are, could have, I mean,
if we had opened in San
Francisco 10 years ago,
maybe we'd be even in a
different type of company, uh,
as far as timing and everything.
But for me,
although we were based in Santa Cruz
for like are for like some personnel
reasons,
Ryan and I,
our goal was never to be the
best coffee in Santa Cruz.
Our goal is to be the best coffee in
the world and to create the best coffee
company in the world.
We just didn't know if anyone was ever
going to even get it or care, but we were,
that was our path was like, I
want our coffee to be, you know,
our influences were my, you know, my
friends out of Oslo, Norway, and you know,
just like what's happening
in Australia and Melbourne.
Like we were really wanting
to step up to that stage.
And I think it's because of that. Uh, and,
and the timing of when we, when we
opened, uh, as early super early adopters,
uh, that's kind of how it
all, how it all came together.
And then once we had those
little opportunities,
we had product that stepped up to
it. I mean, one of our first places,
our brand ever went from
Santa Cruz like two months in,
was straight to the heart of Manhattan
with a cafe grumpy out there,
who at the time was the east
coast caught ritual. Ah,
there's a lot more on these coast now.
But they were very early and someone
came to Santa Cruz and had our coffee.
That was amazing.
Brought a bag of her Ethiopia
Conga and brought it back to them.
And I remember I was working bar and I
had to duck down behind the counter and I
got a call from the manager cafe grumpy.
They said,
we want to feature you
on bar here in Manhattan.
And then that's how all of our strength
in the New York Times heard about us.
And then he wrote about it. It
just, so it was based on quality,
but um,
and I think the idea that
we were trying to think big,
but even just because that's what we
wanted out of the company personally.
Um,
and then that ended up working.
So I guess kind of like secret in
it a little bit. And, and, and,
and as the brand,
the brand's super important,
like straight up like design brand that
always matters to us how we want to
design our stores, customer
experience, how we want to look,
feed what we think of the brand.
We've always really been into
brand and design as well.
So we always thought of that.
That's kind of a two part question,
but you mentioned that when you were
initially picking your first location,
uh, third wave coffee hadn't
really taken off yet. Right. Um,
and obviously in the last 10, uh,
there's been an explosion of that,
especially in the bay area from the
equator, four barrel, et Cetera. Um,
the, the first question is, uh,
amongst the other third wave players,
are there any that you
really admire and why? Um,
and the second piece of
that is how do you see, uh,
how do you see verve in relation to
some of the other players in this space?
What, from, from your perspective,
really sets verve apart from
in the pack? Sure. Yeah, I mean,
well it's kind of split into two groups
really because a lot of the people that
were our biggest,
a couple of people that were
big influences on us when
we were opening Stumptown,
Intelligentsia Ryan,
my business partner,
his brother worked at the blue bottle
kiosk on Linden street when that was all
they had. So we go back in that world.
Those were all influences on us.
And as you know,
there's been a lot of business activity
with a lot of brands including those
three brands. So now that they're
kind of off the table in that regard
in uh,
you know, with the MNA stuff
that's happened, looking to
the other side of things,
what other brands are out there that
now influence us or that I think are
influential? I mean
there's, there's a lot,
I mean I see stuff all the
time on Instagram and new
people brands fall on us or
something. I'm like, who's
this? I check it out. I'm like,
damn, that's a killer logo.
That brand package, that packaging
is cool. I like how they did this.
I see like cold beverage drinks being
made and serving where and I'm like,
that's hot.
I just see it's kind of things happening
all the time here and there and you
know, um, but like the, the
major brands that had, you know,
it had a lot influence on us early just
because you look up to see like, well,
who's doing it and who else is doing it?
And those were the ones we looked up to.
So now we're kind of like on our own
trajectory and how we feel different.
I mean,
we,
I feel like we've always
had service first.
Uh, especially like 10 years
ago and that was super not cool.
And the cliches of like,
you know, you know,
waxed a waxed mustaches and like, you
know, suspenders and all this stuff.
Um, and Rockstar Baristas, we were
like super anti that. In fact,
that's actually one of the main reasons
we never opened in San Francisco is that
we just didn't, there was like an energy
that was happening, very young, young,
tense energy and we were just not,
we didn't want to really
get pulled into that world.
We wanted to just kind
of do our own thing.
And
so I guess maybe that's another way.
We've always just done our own thing
and worried about what we're up to.
I totally influenced and love
seeing what everyone's doing.
I'm super into like all
everything that happens,
but at the end of the day of verb,
we just go to RM.
We kinda just go our own path
and be really nice to people,
really focus on our retail environments.
Being more residential than commercial,
have wholesale program that can step up
and really service like this level of
business but still be like
down to Earth are, you know,
we're putting a liar and Shannon
to our online stuff right now.
And then we have some RTD and some other,
some cool single start of stuff that
we're working on for like new innovative,
like next step stuff with our company.
I drink coffee, uh, occasionally. Um,
don't really think about
what's in my cup too much. Um,
maybe everybody here knows what it is,
but I don't really know much about like
third wave coffee and like what that
movement means. And like was
there a first wave, a second wave?
Is there like a fourth one? Like it went
and I got an ninth, six then third. Okay.
Um,
so I was just kind of wondering,
maybe you could provide some more
context on that and also maybe talk about
where you got your name from.
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, those
are great questions because uh,
yeah, I mean the idea of first
wave, second wave, third wave,
um,
loosely is like first wave is like our
grandparents coffee institutional canned
coffee, Folgers, you ban Maxwell House,
sort of that post war era coffee,
which was really where coffee,
you got big in the u s and really
started the real commercialization and
commoditization of coffee second wave.
So that ran for like 30 years or so.
Then second wave comes about with
basically is Starbucks revolution,
Howard Schultz creating co going from
just like coffee as this thing that you
take two scoops,
put it in here mixed with water and you
have coffee or it's like 25 cent diner
coffee and nickel diner coffee into
now you step into espresso culture,
espresso drinks basically espresso
culture for starters that that came,
that Howard brought from Europe,
um,
after visiting there and
the idea of like $4 coffee,
you know that kind of
concept of espresso culture,
$4 coffee and coffee houses as like
he's coined the term third place,
you know, your work home and this other
place whether it's coffee shopper or not,
but just this idea that coffee isn't
just the senior grandpa drinks in the
morning before going out and like
bailing hay. It's like, cool,
I'm going to like my mom does it
and like meet your friends there.
So that second wave and then third wave
came as like just this next generation
said grew up, everyone grows up on the
previous generation. Grew up on Starbucks,
not me personally,
but just because I grew up in this super
small towns and have Starbucks still
doesn't. Um, but, uh,
that what's next and, and
I, and that there was,
people started finding these little
lots of coffee that tasted difference.
The auction systems that
in the coffee world,
in the niche inside world started
for like the best of Panama auctions,
these couple of excellence auctions where
they started rewarding farmers based
on Cup quality blind and having
auctions for their coffee. Um,
there was a book written
called God and a cup, uh,
that really was a turning point to put
third wave on the map and this and the
gay, you know, and, um,
the Geisha variety of coffee that has
been sort of synonymous with the highest
quality,
although you know
that that symbol is,
is,
is definitely it's game plan in a lot of
places that maybe that coffee shouldn't
grow, but where it still grows the best
la places where we get that coffee,
it's still one of the
best coffees in the world.
So those are kind of like those
three, three phases. So yeah. Yeah.
GRANDPA's coffee,
Starbucks revolution.
And then for lack of a better term,
the hipster coffee world that we all
think of Ms Coffee. Those are like the,
although I'm sure like in 1975 if
you were like 20 and you got coffee,
you thought you were,
you were,
you were a hipster getting coffee
at the hipster coffee shop bridges.
So those are the three areas.
And then, um, everyone,
a lot people ask what's fourth
wave? You know, I'm not,
people are ready to jump
to fourth way right now.
And I've heard like fourth wave
is cold brew, fourth wave is this,
fourth wave is convenience. Fourth
wave is bringing food into your cafes.
Like we brought like a lot of,
uh,
more Melbourne since sort of concepts
into our store. Avocado since like that.
Um, I don't know. I think to me that's
still an extrapolation of third wave.
Fourth wave probably shouldn't really
come for like another 10 or 15 years per
the,
unless we're kind of on a
geometric sort of growth
plan hair. But, um,
yeah. So, and then if we're
on our name, verve, it's,
it originally came because it's, it's a
record label of verve records, verve jet.
It's a jazz label.
And we were just trying to think of names.
We had a million names and Ryan,
cause we both play music and
jazz said what about verve?
And it Kinda just stuck and we looked
it up and was available and kind of sat
with it for awhile and we ended
up calling ourselves that. So,
but it means the spirit and enthusiasm
surrounding the creation of art.
And so once we saw the
definition, I was like, damn,
that really feels right.
Like it's like passion energy.
Like if you have a lot of verve,
you maybe that's the energy you feel
when you come into a river of cafe people
behind the bar.
It's like trying to just be posy.
Oh, I was gonna also ask you how you get
your name. Um, so that was an easy one.
So I'm going to totally pivot
and ask you a tough one. Um,
thanks for coming.
By the way,
I'm just thinking about like coffee has
this like very specific kind of climate
that it grows in and you see it, you
know, and that quick tutorial regions.
And I think anecdotally it seems like a
lot of those regions are also areas of
high conflict. And you look at Central
America or Yemen, parts of Africa,
like what's our role in all of that? And
we're so, so separated from the growers,
um, just because of the nature of how
coffee grows and where we are physically.
Um, do you have a role in that? Like
for good or for bad? Do you have a point
of view on like how our collective hunger
for coffee is hopefully making lives
better and, yeah, that's a good question.
I don't work for the
CIA and I just watched,
I'm totally up to speed on
narcos. So, um, so yeah,
I can answer this
question. Um, it's, you're,
I mean you're right, it's, it's
crazy. I mean like all Latin America,
I mentioned narcos cause that's,
I mean you hear about this when
you travel to all these countries,
you hear about the history of a lot
things that back in the day felt like
conspiratorial and then you're
like, oh yeah. But then everyone,
you just hear it firsthand. Um, you know,
that's like another
talk probably. But, uh,
mmm.
With just US involvement, obviously
I'm not a Latin American studies,
but I'm sure there's people that could
school me all up on that. But it's,
you know, it's, it's, it's tough. Um,
I mean there are certain places that we
don't buy coffee from because it's so
complicated. But I wanted
to travel there. Like,
I can't go to Yemen
right now, but, um, uh,
I mean I've been to Rwanda and
Burundi and I've been in Kenya,
like in part in parts of Ethiopia
and all places in Colombia.
It gets, it can get really real
down there in southern Columbia, but
MMM.
And they,
certain places I can in Columbia,
I can't go and either
overnight or I can't,
you can't even really
go during the daytime.
But we go to a lot of out
there places in Colombia.
But to answer your question,
I see coffee as a lever for change and
I see that lever really saying the word
quality on it. And that's the lever,
the coffee lever that we moved.
And to me I just really believe that
not like what we do is so important.
Like for like we're,
I mean we're just a small sliver,
but all we can do is what we can do.
And we want to do it clearly and loudly.
And that is to just say that that's
probably recently we traveled to go meet
producers is to understand who
they are and to understand what,
how, what, how our approach
can help them. Again,
not out of charity.
Farmers don't want your charity,
they just want to be treated
fairly. But A, we go.
So I,
yeah,
I think one of the best things you can
do is just help help create, you know,
for any farming families help create a
stable economy and something that they
can count on. And some
end if there. And if the,
if you find producers
that have a good address,
their farms in a good spot and they're
willing to put in this extra work because
they're passionate about it,
you see it all the time.
The best farmers are the
most passionate ones.
There's ones that get lucky
but not really. You need,
you do need to have a good site this
side of the hill, this elevation,
the separate macroclimate
this aspect of the soil, this,
but really it comes down to the farmers
passion and hard work and I do feel like
what we do in that way is good because
it opens up opportunities for people to
make more, have more opportunities and
more decision making authority and,
and how they, how they live. But it's
super complex. I mean East Africa,
Yemen come on,
I mean like Kenya even and then
all of Latin America is mostly,
it's, it's, it really simmer down a
lot. But then with aisle the aisle,
everything happened with the cartel
and stuff like that. It's, you know,
it's its own thing, but we try to
steer clear of it and just started,
do what we can to empower farmers.
I wonder about this notion of paying
for quality and a lot of the talk about
like the progression of a
coffee and how it's viewed. Um,
is there anything else or like any other
industries or within the food space
even where you see an opportunity for
that transition to happen where people
have expectations of,
you know,
paying very little for something where
you can see kind of bringing like you
either higher quality options or um,
higher quality brands with
also that higher price tag.
It's, I mean it's probably an
everything to be honest with you.
I mean part of it is what
industries globally are
available for that and part of
it is how we nationally think about food.
So I can remember the statistic off
hand. I've like, I've said it before,
but I'm like the percentage of Americans
spend on food is like really low in the
developing world. It's
like, don't hold me to this,
but it's something like a quarter,
like a lot of people on like
France or Italy spend on food.
It's a part of it is just
a descent d a d sense,
a decent Tizen density to say,
you know what I'm saying?
We are desensitized on the price of food
because of a lot of reasons including
like subsidies and corn
and things like that.
And we see that as the value add is
cheaper is better and bigger is better.
Not this room necessarily,
but that's just this thing that's been
kind of drilled be cut for good reasons
because that's like how people think about
food security is one of the best ways
to like, you know, growing nation. But
so I think you could look at almost
anything and think, well what, what,
what is the version of this that
helps create change in what,
who is in the supply chain that wants
to do better and who's already wants to
produce something better and how
do we help them have a voice?
I mean you could, I mean like
parallel problems ti ti does really,
I mean t t has done really amazing.
I mean really,
really amazing tea growers in China and
Japan can get paid really great prices
for their tea.
I mean you can pick any commodity and
dissect it and try to find out how we
could leverage the people that
want to do quality because I,
I I want,
and I believe it's us helping producers,
but I also think there's just a huge
audience. It just wants better stuff.
Like there's a huge audience of people
that just like I paid 50 50 cents more
for blackberries if they always tasted
amazing or like strawberries or,
I mean you can just pick anything
you eat any fruit and say,
would you be willing to pay 50 cents more?
Because that could be like a
20 30% increase in the price.
It can be applied almost anywhere we
choose just to be focused in coffee.
But I do think about that a lot from,
and that there's an audience that wants,
there's an audience that wants quality
and they want to have this better
experience in their life and they're
willing to pay for it. And there's people,
people that want to produce that,
and it's just connecting those two ends
of the supply chain because without
them, without people producing high
quality anything, there's nothing,
no product for people to buy.
And without people willing to step up
and pay premiums for quality experiences,
then there's no livelihood or
reasonably able to do it. So,
and I believe fundamentally both of
these students in the spectrum exists in
almost everything we touch.
It's just a matter of connecting them.
So then that's what we tried
to do in coffee. Great. Well,
thank you so much for coming.
[inaudible].